boom dude there's nothing cooler than
practically shooting a tentacle
I have a feeling 99 of everything we're
seeing here is a lot simpler than people
expect it to be
oh yeah
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wow that
was perfect that was perfect that was oh
my God
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to express
yourself I'm your host Brandi o Daniel
we're gonna go talk to some people
courtesy of today's sponsor expressvpn
let's see what they have to say hello
everyone how are you hey Nico what if I
was to tell you that surfing the
internet without expressvpn is like
being on a bus on the speakerphone with
everyone being able to hear your phone
call I would cancel my internet if that
was the situation okay well that is the
situation when you're surfing the
internet without expressvpn that's
because you
can basically see everything you're
doing online site to visit time you
spend on them yeah even the stuff you
look at in incognito mode what do you
have to say about that using the
internet without expressvpn is like
drinking water straight from the tap
if I told you that accessing the
internet without expressvpn was like
going to the bathroom in a public place
with the door open oh that's so
embarrassing I've only done it a few
times what if you turned on your
television and there were no shows scary
I was so scared if there's no TV back on
expressvpn allows you to access content
that's not available in your country or
region what would you have to say to
that am I going to jail absolutely not
it's free and open internet that's right
that's how we do things around here free
and open when you access the internet
with expressvpn not only are you able to
access content that's not available in
your country or region like I do when I
like to watch my sports you can also get
additional layers of security and
encryption while your data is out on the
open internet so not only are you better
protected you also get access to the
world of content that's out there and
available for you go to expressvpn.com
Corridor crew and you can find out how
you can get three months free let me
spell that for you
expresvpn.com man not using that gonna
look like a real chump dude anyway
thanks for joining us here on express
yourself and wait whoa whoa I feel it
Trevor
hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
dude wake up it's Saturday open your
mind it's your weekend come on let's
start having fun
you know what's cool just getting into
it let's go
[Music]
oh
yeah oh my God this was the scariest
movie when I was a kid I remember
watching this and I was blown away and
as I returned to re-watch parts of this
movie I am just utterly convinced that
it is a fantastic film it's not just a
genre piece it's not like a horror thing
or a Sci-Fi thing it is a really well
made movie that's also really funny
let's take a look
there's just like distant gunfire
happening it's just like huh what's
going on in there classic other side of
the mountains meanwhile but were those
blanks oh yeah
see that shot oh my God we're
backsliding the reveal of like oh yeah
they have a million guns I love that gun
wall reveal yeah I know it feels like a
scene from like naked gun or something
you know like it's it's very funny
oh
boom dude there's nothing cooler than
practically shooting a tentacle
just wrapped around your ankle happens
in Return of the Jedi
and Lord of the Rings they don't use a
shotgun
so the little mini tentacle guys they're
basically on rods and you can control
the way they're like undulating via like
twisting and turning it and puppeting it
behind that so obviously each time
they're connecting to someone's foot
they are reversing it because they're
not dexterous enough to like wrap around
someone but they are dexterous enough
where if you do have it wrapped around
someone you can unwind it in a smooth
fashion as you can see yeah it looks
like what they did there is they just
did it backwards it probably yeah it
hits his other leg Yeah
[Laughter]
oh yeah yeah all the effects happening I
think you can count on one or two hands
the amount of like Optical Composites in
this movie and this is one of them I was
about to say this is an old school
Optical composite you can see like the
gamma shift on the background there's a
clear white edge around him so like the
matte isn't perfect is that a miniature
or full scale I wonder I'm starting to
think it's a miniature because they're
not showing the actions at the same time
but the one time they did he was a blue
screen element so uh actually the crazy
thing it's actually a mixture of both
miniature and full size that's awesome
and if you go to that very very first
shot when it busts through I was gonna
say it was like she's partially
obscuring it without any evidence of
blue screen right there oh yeah that's
one of the few full-size shots in the
scene they have it on Rails and they're
just zooming it into the set wall wow
you pointed out like you saw that one
shot that was composited to have these
people shooting giant blanks in that
direction I just don't think that would
be safe yeah so that's when they set up
a miniature set and blast this thing
with squibs smoke and the only way to
get that shot safely was to composite
the guy on top of the miniature plate
not to mention when the monster is
flailing around and smashing through the
ceiling getting a full-size animatronic
to move that way is nearly impossible
foreign
this has to be one of the shots where
they use the full-size worm because if
you were to try and do this in a
miniature fashion it would be really
hard to get it to look right like
imagine if this was like half the size
that flare would look comedic basically
it would be like the size of the Sparks
and all that stuff not to mention like
each time you see dust float around in
the room it's like it's at the right
scale because it's it is
[Music]
all that stuff where you're seeing it
burrowing it's actually just like a
giant ball that they have underground
and they have like a whole trench built
basically and then they're yanking this
ball with a cable that's just going
through the Earth and breaking all of
them all of the stuff they've laid down
on top of it it's definitely definitely
like the ultimate practical Effects
movie more often than not it's just
experimenting and coming up with a good
idea gives you an effect that's just as
good as if not better than anything
that's like super expensive it's like oh
what if we just put a ball on a chain
and hooks up to like you know Joe's 4x4
and just dragged it through the ground
it's like oh that looks just like a worm
going through the ground
yeah
whoa can you fly you sucker
oh heck yeah this is a big slug dude
[Applause]
yeah that's pretty good that's pretty
good oh there's so much liquid in that
thing they just pumped it full of
Gatorade and just let it drop it was so
awesome this guy's all scored and sliced
up so that all the goo comes out yeah
you're right so that shot of it Landing
is also still then a miniature right it
looks large scale and like you were
saying that means they have to film that
in slow-mo you can kind of tell it's
filmed in slow-mo you can kind of see it
has a little bit of slow-mo feel
I wonder what scale that is the liquid
is is so like thick it's probably like a
six foot long worm I'm guessing yeah I
was about to say that's probably like
the human sized one wait that's a
full-size thing like go back go back
yeah wait no it's comp Tim at the top
there yeah you can see that the frame
Jitter from the film going through it's
just his element that's comped right
because in the whole sky but look at all
the smoke and stuff that's going over it
because there's no matte lines on the
dust or sand or stuff I think they just
have it masked so that where the rocks
move they notice how they don't go over
any clouds yeah like it could just be
masked but also notice how the matte
line by Kevin Bacon ends right where the
dust is see how there's like that kind
of black Edge the matte line oh yeah guy
in the wall honestly just watching it in
motion shows that it's composited well
I'm kind of curious about the last shot
too because it looks the best I'm
curious how they would get the hole in
the cliff oh what if it's actually
forced perspective oh it could be you're
right oh my goodness God yeah he could
just be literally on the roof of like
the studio building he might just be on
like some scaffolding and they just no
you're right that looks like a forced
perspective shot because I don't see any
comp work going on I don't see the
Jitter I don't see anything weird with
his character that's basically just the
miniature Cliff across the camera and
he's back there way up high so I think
one of the reasons why this movie is so
great is because they storyboarded every
single shot in the film it was
meticulously planned out there's no
coverage it is pure intention and I
think when you put that much planning
into a piece like this it generally
turns out really well there were more
Tremors movies after that right so I
assume there are more trimmers VFX leave
a comment down below suggesting which
trimmers VFX from the sequels we should
take a look at so I'm going to show you
guys some tick tocks this one crater
called
hmm
what do you notice that's odd about
these tick tocks well uh nothing jumps
out to me yet so is it weird that
there's just no one in any of these
shots ever yeah so this is a tick tock
Channel dedicated to this person that's
spoken up in this world with no one in
it and it's just an empty world and he's
like on a cruise ship and there's no one
around no one driving the boat snowing
in these cities incredibly easy to do if
you just time it to where there's no one
around but it's hard to time some things
where there's no way yeah like
especially in a city when there's always
going to be someone walking around
[Music]
foreign
S no I don't think so what is this I
think we're looking at a mix of just
good timing good editing good camera
work and some painting out there's
actually some really handy AI tools that
remove things from frames but you'll
also notice like there's Choice Cut
points you know yeah very Choice things
being revealed sometimes it's like
barely shows the feet very selective
field of view here right they didn't
show anybody to the left to the right of
that angle and it's off season so
there's not a lot of tourists there if
there's no one around how did he get
from America to Europe
actually that's part of the story
hahaha
play all right you got me I have a
feeling 90
of everything thing we're seeing here is
a lot simpler than people expect it to
be yeah well first off most of his shots
are at Sunrise and if you know anything
about filmmaking you know the fun story
behind 28 Days Later where they're like
wow how did you get that crazy shot in
London or he's walking around and
downtown and it's empty and well it was
really simple and they just said the way
we did the shot is by waking up super
early and filming it the moment there
was enough light to get an exposure and
there was no one around so I know these
kind of look like nurse and they kind of
look like Photo scans like it's weird
like I can see why people are like this
is Unreal Engine five like it's not
Unreal Engine five Unreal Engine five
doesn't look like this and stop Nerfs
and it's probably not photo scans no I
don't see any of the classic artifacting
that you would get with a Nerf you get
like these little floaters around the
edges and this we're seeing extremely
good detail off in the distance and the
flare from the Sun is the classic flare
that you'd get in an iPhone lens so
that's also kind of betraying the sort
of rendered look that you would get with
a neural Radiance field and it's
definitely not just a simple photo scan
because then you have to render it out
and that's just going to make it look CG
which this does not look
[Music]
well look that's actually a really great
shot he says I painted graffiti on the
tower meaning he's messing with visual
effects okay because there's obviously
he didn't put graffiti on the tower he's
doing motion tracking and so just right
there that shot establishes the fact
that all these shots that we're seeing
can be manipulated with visual effects
and the simplest answer is that he's
probably just doing occasional paint
outs and motion tracking on these shots
to remove movement and people from his
shots but this gets a lot more
complicated when the camera is moving
through 3D space like this if the camera
is just like static or just looking
around but not moving really easy just
to track in a Clean Plate but what gets
me is that he's still moving the camera
around which doesn't make it impossible
just UPS the difficulty
oh they do do visual effects okay oh
yeah he doesn't care at all I mean
that's actually a pretty sweet little uh
yeah motion tracking spot on once again
they are very much demonstrating that
they have the abilities to do this
absolutely little things like this I
think are like the few things that
really establish like the Artistry
potential of social media this kind of
Storytelling is like so unique and just
works perfectly on a platform like this
well done kill Maru all right okay
everybody listen listen Open the
analytics Nick is telling me to do this
look we started this on YouTube Okay so
we're allowed to do it guess the
percentage of subscribed viewers 20 no
percent no 10 No 5 41 no 93 close wait
really what yeah eighty percent of you
watching are subscribed it's working
it's finally happened so I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna say anything anymore thank
you thank you thank you hey thanks for
subscribing
I know you love Darby o'gilly it's my
favorite movie The VFX supervisor
specifically referenced Darby o'gilly
talking about this movie no way yeah
giant oh oh my God this movie wait
Indian in the Cupboard I loved this
movie as a kid
[Music]
whoa
wow
that was perfect that was perfect that
was oh my god there was Parallax changed
with his body and everything what an
incredible shot grade A compositing this
is the kind of compositing that we're
looking at in 1995 and we're still
trying to get this good at compositing
holy crap was this ilm yeah this is iLab
of course it's ilm of course I mean this
is just crazy this is just really really
really really really good composite oh
my God because I'm really confused where
the composite starts in this shot
because when he's walking in the
cupboard it looks so good but having an
upscaled set cupboard with that level of
detail and having the fingers there it
starts to make no sense only the actor
is composite so yeah I was about to say
I think I noticed because I was looking
at his shadow as he goes across the
little threshold there and it like folds
down so I think it's his real Shadow
that's being projected onto the blue
screen but it cuts off and it turns into
a painted on Shadow that folds Across
the Threshold there they actually have a
giant blue screen hand that he steps
onto also oh wow wow really yeah because
I wondered I was like like he jumps on
something but then the camera moves as
we follow him so he's having to be
motion tracked onto the real footage of
the hand but there's Parallax with him
so whatever he's getting on has to be at
least moving yeah perspective does
change he could also just be rotating in
place so how I would do that shot is
like the shot filming him is locked off
and as it gets on the thing then that
rotates slightly to time up with The
Parallax that you'd get as we follow the
hand up to his face yep and they have
like the boy slightly holding his thumb
up so it covers the contact point on his
hand that's like a super protein these
are subtle tricks right like the
difference between this and this is
having an effect that looks amazing
having an effect that looks like garbage
yeah it's literally that simple having
this knowledge of like what works and
what doesn't you need to alter the shot
just a little bit suddenly it's way
easier it's way better versus being
impossible in janky and that's I mean
that's a common complaint is having like
directors or you know cinematographers
that don't understand visual effects and
they film stuff not for visual effects
and suddenly you have a shot that just
doesn't sell as well or it's really hard
to do and all you need to do is just
move the camera two inches this way and
it's perfect there's a certain magic
surrounding the mid 90s movies that had
ilm working on them because there
weren't that many VFX shots so that
meant every single VFX shot was a hero
shot you wanna see my favorite shot from
the movie yeah it's coming over here
okay
foreign
whoa I think this is the first case of a
lightsaber actually Illuminating the
environment also wait yeah
it's like a perfect lightsaber like yeah
it it blurs out correctly yeah so you
see this in all the Star Wars prequels
all they did with the lightsabers was
like Roto it make it white and then give
it a glow but in real life when stuff's
being motion blurred the more it's
moving the more the exposure comes down
so a hot lightsaber the base where it's
not moving much in the frame will stay
white but the edge of the fan where it's
moving really fast across frame you get
a lot of motion blur will come down in
exposure and you actually see this in
the most recent Star Wars films they're
finally starting to do that effect the
correct physically accurate effect but
this is 1995. and I think this is the
first time you have that actually
happening with the lightsaber they have
the correct motion blur exposure change
from the top of the lightsaber is not
white but kind of like a like a rich
pinkish red and it becomes white towards
the hilt and it's Illuminating the world
around Darth Vader and the T-Rex you
know why I bet it's real you're right
it's probably a practical that whole set
that is probably a real set because at
least the top half obviously the T-Rex
is going to be CG here but it's not that
hard just to make a little platform and
then the two walls that he's standing up
against and if they have an actual real
tube filled with red light Illuminating
that part of the scene you would get
that exact effect and the reason why
we're praising how real it looks is
probably because it is real I feel like
they probably just filmed a real glowing
tube and he's probably just holding a
fluorescent light bulb probably right
he's not hitting anything with it he's
not having a spar he's just yeah
swinging it around there's a star I
think there's a Klingon in the back in
there too oh yeah oh yeah there's like
that that one guy with weird big ears
yeah for Angie just getting wrestled by
the Klingon it's not a Klingon it's a oh
wait I forget the name of it but it's
not a Klingon oh okay sorry
you didn't want to fully reveal how
nerdy you are I don't know okay with
Jesus
it's like what it was like Star Trek
races what's the name of that guy
Kardashian
excuse me it's one of the Kardashians
yes Kim Kardashian
see
the Kardashian these guys you're right
you're right yeah
look at that shot
whoa dude that's a Flawless shot this is
a perfect visual effect shot with zero
technical flaws and it sells itself the
whole shot is real in camera except for
the dude yeah yeah the out of focus
Twigs being composited over him yeah
that's Insanity I don't see any other
way around this other than like motion
controlled cameras it has to be right
this has to be just
rigs so they would have filmed the shot
first with some sort of motion control
rig where that's actually recording the
motion as it goes around it so now that
they have the data for that they can
scale that up these days we do it with
just like a robot arm and go through the
same camera motion and there's a very
clever move at the beginning here so
let's say once again you're filming your
real actor on a blue screen in this case
well to do this motion control okay to
have the camera 50 feet back yeah you
know at the beginning here if that chest
wasn't in the way the camera would have
to go like hundreds of feet back so by
revealing them halfway through the shot
yeah they only had to pull the camera
back as far away as we see from the
actor here and the other really
interesting thing they discovered is you
know they're doing motion control on the
actor and they're doing motion control
in real life and it's scaled but when
you then take the actor and you stick
them to that part of the model like you
know you have the motion control so it
kind of sticks but then when you have an
artist go in and like Pixel Perfect
stick them to things it just totally
fixes all the like the issues of them
connecting I saw a little bit of sliding
a little bit right there it's a tiny
little bit he's got like this little
cloth dangling behind him on whatever
sort of rig he's sitting on but that
cloth kind of slides a little bit right
here yeah it's just very subtle so
subtle like you can't even notice it
there's one other really challenging and
clever thing happening here as you guys
pointed out which is filming things in
close-up when they're tiny you get very
shallow depth of field you can see how
like the sticks go out of focus really
fast it's challenging because they can't
get an aperture that wide to film the
actor but they make up participant being
very precise keeping the focus locked on
that point as the motion control happens
and then of course rotoing out these out
of focus objects in front of him which I
I don't know how they did it I mean just
a feathered mask you know it's like it
just requires very specific fine-tuning
of making that feather big enough so
here's the problem with that though
let's say you have something that's very
out of focus and you're trying to like
rotoscope that and put that in front of
someone else where do you put the line
because if it's a wide line well then
suddenly now you're dealing with this
bokeh that has elements of your
background still within that and then if
you make it too small well then your
nice bokeh is lost completely and it
just tightens up and even if you make it
a happy medium like all right a little
bokeh and then a little tighten up
there's still that the remnants of the
background within the bokeh we can see
it here so watch it you can actually see
the background come through that out of
focus stick yeah right there just a
little bit so when it's in front of him
it's a smaller stick right here yeah
right yeah see when it passes in front
of the stick behind it you can see the
stick behind it in the out of focus
blurriness of the stick in front oh also
uh fun trivia this movie was directed by
Yoda
really really yep Frank Oz is the voice
puppeteer of Yoda and he directed this
movie huh directing I will
can't I say
so ambulance is a movie that Michael Bay
directed this came out last year and the
reason why I love this so much is that
there's a lot of really incredible fpv
Drone footage in it from a company
called lightcraft the main pilot on this
is Alex Van over he's a super incredible
pilot and he had one shot to fly
underneath a flying cop car that went
off a ramp and he didn't know that
there's going to be another cop car
right behind it and he just barely
missed it
[Music]
foreign
I think they replaced the bottom of the
car and also they put CG rocks over the
ramp this movie wasn't that high budget
especially for a classic Michael Bay
movie but they did destroy a lot of cars
they had a real ambulance that they're
driving around these are real stunt cars
and they're trying to get as much of
this done practically and yet there's
this one shot on the highway that I was
like okay those were not real but so
many people were like but they had to be
real everything else was real right
[Applause]
it's definitely CG that's definitely CG
this is definitely CG the camera goes
through it
all right you would plan a shot like
this and have the Drone go through it I
feel like that's like an afterthought it
is so weird having the drum go through
the car I mean who knows what the shoe
making process behind having the shot
continue for a second maybe it was like
we wanted the car crash to happen here
but we wanted the shot to end here and
you can't just like have the car crash
happen and then just continue going down
the road breaking physics I'm almost
certain that the thought process is this
looks cool yeah you know that's all you
need to do that's all you got to do it's
a cool shot though absolutely that's
cool I mean there's a lot of cool shots
in this movie hey if you've been
watching this show regularly on
Saturdays well we have an extended
version on our website Corridor
digital.com it's usually like a half an
hour long and it helps support us to
stay independent and make this content
just for you so check it out thank you
so much for watching we'll check back in
next week to see if you're still here
bye yo latest